you can imagine the flood and then you
can set yourself straight and then you
can prepare for it and that means maybe
you can stave it off but it also means
that maybe even if you don't stave it
off you can ride it out and that's
actually the story of Noah because what
happens with Noah is that he can see
that things are not good and that
there's a flood coming and God is maybe
letting him know and it says in the
story that Noah walked with God remember
that's what Adam did before he got all
self-conscious about the whole thing he
walked with God we'll talk about that
more next time but what that would mean
maybe is because Noah was straight and
he put himself together and his familial
relationships were good because it also
says that that his antennae were working
and he could see a little farther into
the future than someone whose vision was
completely obscured by by fog and chaos
and he could tell that things were not
going to go well and so he prepared for
it and because he prepared for it well
then things actually went pretty well
for Noah even though the flood came and
so that's an interesting thing because
that's a that's an indeterminant issue
in human existence how big a hurricane
would it take to wipe out New Orleans if
everyone was prepared well the you're
not going to wipe out the Dutch I mean
that's going to be a tough one man
you're going to have to conjure up a
pretty damn big storm to take out their
dikes
well how thoroughly defended to New
Orleans be if nobody in the municipality
municipal and state governments was
corrupt well end of the hurricane
problem because that's something that we
could clearly deal with we know how to
do it and the same applies in your own
life is that there are floods coming you
can bloody well be sure of that
that's absolutely 100 percent certain
some of them are going to be personal
some of them are going to be familial
some of they're going to be social and
political and economic it's like are
they going to be catastrophes for you or
are you going to ride them out are you
going to prepare well the first issue
might be well do you have your act
together well enough to see them coming
with enough advance warning so that you
can take proper measures maybe just
decide step it maybe just don't go where
the flood is going to be that's a simple
thing but maybe you don't have that
luxury right and so it is going to be a
catastrophe maybe someone in your family
is going to get really really sick right
and maybe maybe there's just a tiny
pathway through that that everything
doesn't fall apart it doesn't end in
divorce it doesn't end in death it
doesn't end in sorrow doesn't end in
catastrophe but the margin of error is
like slimmed down to virtually zero and
every imperfection that you bring to
that situation is going to increase the
probability that that tragedy is going
to turn into something indistinguishable
from hell and that's coming it's coming
your way
absolutely certainly and so then you
might think well since it's coming your
way maybe the best thing to do is to put
yourself together so that when it comes
it can be the least amount of awful
possible so I'll close with the story
this was a very affecting story for me
my mother-in-law had frontal temporal
dementia and she developed it quite
young she's about 55 something like that
and her husband who was very extroverted
man-about-town guy I grew up in a small
town everybody knew him he was
charismatic drank too much charismatic
good businessman quite a remarkable
person a real character but not exactly
a family man even though he he provided
for his family very well but when his
wife got sick he really took care of her
man it was something to see because
that's no joke dealing with someone who
has Alzheimer's for all intents and
purposes because they get taken away
from you piece by piece and that is not
pretty and then it's also hard right not
only is it catastrophic but it's hard
Jesus he just stepped into that like
perfectly and it was way less awful than
it could be Wayne it was just a tragedy
it wasn't hell and then
I was there when she died and my wife's
family are actually pretty good at
dealing with death as it turns out my
wife's sister is a palliative care nurse
and you have to be pretty tough cookie
to be a palliative care nurse but you
can do it which is pretty interesting
because that means that you can go make
relationships with people at the last
stages of their life that are genuine
relationships and people just die on you
non-stop and yet you know she's a
competent alive alert fun person it's
like two thumbs up for her man that's
someone you can rely on in the tragedy
and her other sister is a pharmacist and
my wife has volunteered in palliative
care Awards and is also very good at
taking care of people who are genuinely
not in good health and so we were there
when my mother-in-law died and of course
you could imagine here's a here's a
deathbed situation for you your
mother-in-law is dying and everyone's at
each other's throats it's like you think
that's uncommon then your eyes aren't
open because it's plenty bloody common
and then it's not just a tragedy its
hell and like maybe you can stand the
tragedy but you can't stand the hell and
in this situation that isn't what
happens everybody pulled together and
what happened was all she died but what
was so interesting was the family
actually came together more tightly as a
consequence and so although there was
something taken away on the one hand
there was something gained on the other
that wasn't trivial and I'm not trying
to be all optimistic and you know isn't
the universe a wonderful place about all
this like someone died in an ugly way
and it was harsh but god it was a hell
of a lot better than it could have been
and maybe it was good enough that's the
thing you know is that this is something
that I constantly wonder is that if
people did what they could to speak the
truth and pay attention then maybe the
tragedy that's part of life wouldn't
have to deteriorate into the unbearable
hell that doesn't have to be
part of life and maybe we could actually
tolerate the tragedy and maybe we could
even rise above it and maybe we could
even mitigate it you know because we can
we do that sort of thing all the time
and so it's always an open question
Llanelli odd had put it very well are
the floods the consequence of the fact
that things fall apart or are the floods
a consequence of the fact that people
make mistakes that they know they
shouldn't make and make anyways they sin
right and that's to miss the mark right
because that's an archery term to sit
and that means maybe they don't even
specify the damn target which is really
you're not going to hit it unless you
specified or having specified it they
just say Oh to hell with it it's not
that important it's like you know to be
careful when you say something like to
hell with it
it's not that important because one of
the things that might happen to you if
you say to hell with it
it's not that important is that you
might actually end up in hell for a
pretty prolonged period of time or maybe
for the remainder of your miserable
existence because it's certainly the
case that people do exist there and I've
seen them exist there and once you're
there it's no trick it's no simple
matter to get the hell out and so it
might matter that the things that matter
get addressed it might matter that you
do what you can to walk with God like I
said we'll talk more about God next time
and it might be that that is how you
build an ark and are protected from the
flood even if the damn thing comes and
the thing is it will and this is a funny
thing too that I've noticed about our
education system and the way we teach
students and their trigger warnings and
all of that absolute rubbish I think in
most of my lectures I'd have to have a
trigger warning every 15 seconds so like
online students when they're young it's
like look don't fool yourself you know
you're going to develop a serious
illness at least one maybe two or three
and one of them is likely to be chronic
and if it isn't you it's going to be
someone you love it's going to be your
husband it's going to be your parent
it's going to be your kids
coming and so is a lot of death and sand
pain and so like just exactly what sort
of person are you going to be when that
shows up and that's the right question
it isn't how are you going to be happy
in your life it's like good luck with
that
it's a stupid ambition anyways as far as
I'm concerned because it's too shallow
you know happiness you're lucky that
comes it comes and goes like the Sun
coming out from behind the cloud if
you're happy man more power to you enjoy
it enjoy it it's a it's a gift from the
cosmos to be happy but a pursuit no no
the pursuit is when the damn flood comes
you want to be the person who built Ark
and that's what the story of Noah is
about and the thing is the flood is
always coming that's another thing
that's worth commenting on with regards
to this story is you know there's an
apocalyptic element to the
judeo-christian tradition there's an
idea that the end of the world is always
at hand and that you should prepare to
be judged and the thing about that is
it's true and the reason it's true is
because the end of your world is at hand
and it will certainly come and when it
comes you will be judged because it will
be up to you to figure out what to do
with the fact that your world just
collapsed and that'll be a moral problem
of ultimate severity because it will
push you right to your limits and you'll
find out exactly where your unaddressed
weaknesses lie because that's what
happens in a crisis and so the reason
that that's an archetypal reality and it
lurks underneath the entire
judeo-christian structure the apocalypse
the impending apocalypse is because we
always live in apocalyptic times and
your world is always in small ways and
large ways coming to an end and so what
do you do you prepare for it you prepare
for your world to come to an end and
then maybe when the end comes you get
another world that'd be a good deal